la france symbole européen de la lutte
contre les violences policières
aux yeux de la presse étrangère alors
que les états unis connaissent une
mobilisation de grande ampleur
une semaine après la mort de georges
floyd au moins vingt mille personnes ont
bravé l'interdiction de manifester mardi
à paris et ont répondu à l'appel du
collectif vérité pour adama traoré dans
les rues de la capitale
adama traoré d'orge floyd deviennent
alors les visages d'une même lutte
contre certaines pratiques racistes et
parfois mortelle des forces de l'ordre
une manifestation loin d'être passé
inaperçu
hors des frontières du pays en europe
c'est en france que l'on trouve le
mouvement le plus actif est organisée de
lutte contre ces pratiques policières
qui selon les militants vise de façon
disproportionnée les populations noires
et arabes
ici la sphère emblématique est celle
d'adama traoré un français noirs de 24
ans qui est mort en 2016 pendant une
opération de police et dont le nom a
resurgi avec une force particulière à la
fin de mai
la sphère traoré a cristallisé la colère
suscitée par les violences policières en
france
les méthodes brutales de la police
nationale sont devenues un problème pour
la population blanche pendant les
manifestations des gilets jaunes entre
novembre 2018 et le printemps 2010 9
si la sphère adama traoré a débuté lors
du décès de ce jeune homme de 24 ans
après une interpellation des forces de
l'ordre en 2016
le cas de georges floyd aux états unis
révèle le débat sur le racisme et les
violences policières qui mobilise bien
au delà des états unis et de la france
de londres à berlin de rio de janeiro à
montréal des manifestations étaient
organisées aux quatre coins de la
planète après la mort de georges floyd
figure malgré lui de l'antiracisme